well that one better than expected
so Spain had an election yesterday
and it looked like the conservatives had the upper hand
potentially ousting Prime Minister Pedro Sanchez
of the Socialist Party
and the conservatives did gain 47 seats in Congress
getting them a total of 136 more than the Socialists
but that's not enough to outright win the election
so they're going to spend the next few days or weeks
trying to convince lawmakers from these smaller parties
to back them
with the goal of forming a coalition of at least
176 congressional seats so they can form a government
the good news is
the far right Vox party did much worse than expected
so the conservatives making a deal with them
would not be enough to get to 176
so things aren't as bad as expected for Pedro Sanchez
but it's far from a real victory
if he manages to get a majority to back his government
he'll barely keep his job and
if neither party's able to get to 176 votes in Congress
Spain will have to have another election soon
and you need to follow for more in case that happens